Oui, c'est la rentrée.
Mais je reprends les vidéos !
Je préfère.
J'ai écrit une suite à mes vidéos sur les jeux vidéo,
j'voulais pas spécialement la faire,
mais vous avez été très nombreux à me la demander,
et puis j'ai fait une rencontre assez douloureuse qui m'a donné envie d'en parler.
C'était une meuf avec qui je discutais,
à un moment on parlait de jeux vidéo,
et je racontais que je jouais en moyenne une heure par jour sur PC, sur console.
Et elle m'a dit :
Hé, faut grandir un peu. Les jeux vidéos, c'est pour les petits enfants.
Et là, j'ai regardé son téléphone, elle avait trois pages de jeux !
La meuf, ses journées c'est :
Le matin, 15 minutes de Candy Crush.
À midi, 15 minutes de 2048.
En rentrant, 15 minutes de Ruzzle.
Et le soir, 15 minutes de Temple Run.
Elle joue autant que moi !
Ah non, mais moi, c'est pas des jeux vidéo.
C'est quoi alors ?! Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est des... applications.
C'est dans la catégorie "Jeux", tu joues sur un écran,
désolé de te l'apprendre comme ça Marlène, mais tu joues à des jeux vidéo !
Soit à quoi elle m'a répondu :
C'est ça, ferme ta gueule !
Aaaah !
Ça va mieux.
Y a un autre truc qui m'énerve pas mal,
ce sont certains puristes qui jouent sur PC.
Quand tu cherches sur un forum une aide pour choisir entre la Xbox One et la PS4,
t'es sûr que le premier message va parler de PC.
Les mecs veulent pas répondre à la question, mais ils répondent quand même.
J'hésite entre deux paires de chaussures.
Prenez un scooter.
Ça va plus vite, un scooter.
Je joue aussi sur PC,
mais, pour moi, c'est impensable de pas avoir une console.
Je le vivrais trop mal, les jeux exclusifs sur console.
C'est mon ...
Stop, stop, stop !
Désolé mais... t'as pas le droit de rentrer au fait.
Ah ... Ah ?
C'est pas moi qui décide, hein, j'y peux rien !
D'accord.
Allez ! Bonne journée, quand même ! Au revoir !
Les jeux, ça évolue tellement, on a des trucs de ouf, aujourd'hui !
Y a des jeux de rôle avec des cartes immenses, avec un nombre dingue de personnages !
Le problème c'est qu'ils ont qu'une seule réplique !
Bonjour, je chercher le château. Peut-être que vous savez où est ce que...
Ah ! Là je vous dois une fière chandelle !
Ah ouais non, mais ça y a pas de problèmes sur les dragons.
Par contre, je cherche le château, il paraît que c'est près ...
Ah ! Là je vous dois une fière chandelle !
Comment tu t'appelles ?
OK, ta gueule, ta gueule.
Faut pas parler à lui, il est ultra relou. Il répète tout tout le temps, je le déteste, j'ai envie de brûler sa famille.
Ouais.
J'peux t'aider ?
Ouais, je cherche le château, au fait. Ça fait deux heures.
On m'a dit que c'était par là...
Hé, faut pas parler à lui, il est extrêmement relou. Il répète tout tout le temps, je le déteste, j'ai vraiment envie de brûler sa famille.
J'peux t'aider ?
Hé, faut pas parler à lui, il est extrêmement relou, il répète tout tout le temps.
D'ailleurs, dans les jeux de rôle japonais,
ils font souvent un truc super bizarre, ça fait 25 ans qu'ils font ça dans les jeux :
Quand tu sors du village, tu fais la taille du village.
Au calme.
Euh, excusez-moi, je cherche le château.
Regardez ! Un géant ! Il nous attaque !
J'imagine que vous allez pas de dire où est le château ?
Ah oui, c'est vrai que vous aimez bien répéter la même chose.
Regardez ! Un géant !
Voilà !
C'est beaucoup mieux.
Un style que j'aime bien, même si j'suis pas du tout doué,
c'est les jeux de tir, les FPS.
Les FPS ça se joue sur PC, hein.
Ta gueule !
Bon, les jeux de tir c'est pas beaucoup plus crédible que les jeux de rôle, hein.
Les mecs changent d'armes en une demi seconde.
C'est vrai que c'est pratique, sinon ça serait un peu relou.
Hop ! Coup de couteau !
Hé mais c'est ... Hé mais c'est mon arme !
Bon par contre, ça commence à devenir un petit peu prévisible, hein.
Surtout les campagnes solo.
Je sais pertinemment quand il va y avoir des ennemis.
Je sais pas pourquoi, mais j'ai l'impression qu'il va se passer un truc.
Les ennemis dans les jeux de tir,
ils sont tous cons à vouloir nous mettre des trucs pour qu'on se protège, on est d'accord ?
J'suis pas sûr que ce soit une bonne idée parce qu'en arrivant, les ennemis vont pouvoir se cacher...
Regarde à quoi j'ai pensé :
Un bidon de fioul !
Juste ici !
Comme ça, si on a besoin de fioul, on a du f...
Les jeux d'aventure, aussi. Super prévisibles. Pour un truc tout con : les logos de sauvegarde.
Quand tu vois un logo de sauvegarde, tu sais, tu le sais, qu'il va se passer un truc !
Moi je veux bien un logo de sauvegarde dans ma vie !
Je suis preneur !
Pourquoi ça sauvegarde ?
Chéri, faut qu'on parle.
Non...
Y a deux mois, j'ai rencontré quelqu'un. Il est chirurgien et pompier volontaire.
Non non non non non...
Il joue pas aux jeux vidéo, il fait énormément de sport.
Non non, je n'entends rien !
Il est batteur dans un groupe de rock.
Je n'entends rien du tout ! La la la la la !
J'sais si tu connais Coldplay...
Je redémarre ! Redémarrage !
Ah voilà, c'est mieux.
Chéri, faut qu'on parle.
Oh merde ! Non non ! La la la la !
Ah, au fait ! Vous êtes 4 millions de fans sur ma page Facebook !
Merci beaucoup ! Vraiment euh...
Je vous donne en échange...
Une vie supplémentaire !
Sinon, y a un truc que j'adore dans les jeux vidéo...
Mais je sais pas le faire...